my name is Kate brights I live in the
Peak District and I'm a self-employed
personal carer or a PA I work with the
elderly I work with vulnerable people to
her clients Kate is a guardian angel in
a four by four we medicate we wash we
get people up to get people to beds we
feed people depend on their requirements
I do not work for the NHS I work for
myself I work for the clients she's also
a mum juggling childcare like millions
of others and because she's not a key
worker in a government recognized
profession her daughter will be coming
home from school and there's no
childcare in place I don't want to take
a virus into the clients but I cannot
have my child out of school I am more
worried that one of my clients or all my
clients will get this virus I can only
help protect the people I have within my
circle hello one of Kate's clients is
Jean one of millions of elderly
vulnerable people about to be shielded
from this pandemic well I think it's a
very worrying situation for everybody
but especially for me because I can't
get out except in a wheelchair and I
have to rely on people to come in and
help especially my carers and it's
worrying if anything happens to them
then really panic Kate visits Jean four
times a day
and if Kate can't come it's down to a
family member unless they have the virus
if Kate's daughter has to stay off
school she says she has no choice but to
bring her along there are instances
where I will be in a bathroom with a
client for half an hour and then snow
buddy watching my child and what happens
if you stop working if I stop work the
clients cannot go into respite because
the doors are closed on the Care Homes
Kate's next step is Bakewell to the home
of Shirley plant a multiple sclerosis
sufferer in her eighties I can hardly
think the future
I don't know it's like it but for me
it's um in a way it's a continuation of
my present situation except that I am
more more dependent on carers of course
now so I don't know where we are and
there we all are in uncertain times
taking life day by day Nick Martin Sky
News Derbyshire